there are there are there are a lot of
people out there who disagree with that
point of view some of them believe that
the the vaccines are in some way harmful
the science as you say it's pretty clear
that that's not the case there are
others who say for some reason that this
should be an individual choice that we
should just allow parents and doctors to
make this decision on their own what do
you say to those people who have this
view that the government there should be
no mandates of any kind of government
should never be involved in this well I
would agree with them that it was an
individual choice if they were the only
ones being affected but recognize we're
all in this together our children are in
this together we don't live in isolation
so your decision does not affect only
you it's sort of like second-hand
smoking
yeah you don't get to say well it's only
affecting me it doesn't affect all these
other people around me that's a very
selfish attitude to have so so Senator
Paul today has now issued a statement
twice in a row yesterday and then today
he's issued the same basically the same
statement where he said that a vaccine
should be voluntary and like most
medical decisions between doctor and
patient not the government I think if
I'm hearing you right
well you said a second ago is hearing
what he's just said to hear what you
just said you would say that that view
is a selfish point of view on his part I
don't want to necessarily talk about
what what he said to be honest with you
because I'm sure if you had an in-depth
conversation with him you'd come away
with a very different impression because
he's actually a very reasonable person
well but the fact of the matter is dr.
Carson we have we have to understand
that there is public policy and there is
health policy that we have to pay
attention to dr. Carson I'm not trying
to create a fight between you and Rand
Paul but I got to say this is second
time today you've suggested that if one
understood his views in full when we'd
come away with a different impression
he's done several interviews on that he
has as some have said double down on
this notion that this is an individual
choice and that there are medical risks
that if parents think outweighed the
benefits of getting vaccine that
vaccination for their kids they
shouldn't do it so you said today that
if if someone had that view it would be
callous and not taking into account
public safety that seems to be his
position or you are you still saying
despite his clear enunciation of his
views
that he's being misunderstood and he
agrees with you
I would I would ask I I would ask him
that question directly and see what he
has to say well but you've you've said
to us and earlier today that he's
misunderstood I'll just give you the
choice again are you saying that if you
if one understood his views he would
agree with you or are you saying that
his position is callous seems to me it's
one or the other no I know it's not one
or the other
I'm saying that there is no need to for
us to sit there and judge what he's
saying without actually sitting him down
and asking him do you believe that it is
a selfish thing for someone not to
vaccinate themselves and expose others
to the risk of disease and as a
physician see what he has to say
dr. Carson you're a physician and he's a
physician I'll give you another quote of
his today it seems pretty clearly in
context he says I've heard of many
tragic cases of walking talking normal
children who wound up with profound
mental disorders after vaccines I just
want to ask you as a medical
professional whether you think that
there is any basis for that statement
there have been many stories of like
that that have circulated have I ever
encountered one no so is there a medical
basis for his statement I think there
probably are people who may make a
correlation where one does not exist and
then that sort of ignites and catches
fire and spreads and that's probably the
source of those things I am not aware of
scientific evidence of a direct course
there's one thing for a talk radio host
or a politician who doesn't have a new
medical degree to say those things but I
just I just wonder as a doctor whether
you're troubled that amongst those who's
saying this is is Senator Paul who is a
doctor
well he keeps retired I believe as a
physician but you know everybody is
entitled to their opinion but not the
important thing is for us every the
important thing is for us to make sure
that the populace understands that there
is no substantial risks and that the
benefits are extremely significant and
that we fire addict ated you take and
you're in your stance everyone's
entitled their opinion that if a medical
doctor goes around saying at a public
way
vaccines are dangerous and it's autism
and it should be up to the parents not
public policy you're fine with that you
just chopped it up to somebody else's
opinion even if they're a doctor even
doctors are entitled to their opinions
but I say ask him those direct questions
and see what he has to say